- Have things we want.
We don't get what we want,
we get what we have to have.
There have been people
that have been through the most
horrific experiences in life
and they found a way to still be happy
'cause they've made the decision
that life is too short to suffer.
Here's what I've done.
I think I have the ability
to influence people
'cause I talk about my failures.
I talk about all the
things that messed me up
but I show people that
I didn't let it stop me
and you don't need to let it stop you.
- He's an American businessman,
author, and philanthropist.
He served as an advisor to
leaders around the world
for almost 40 years.
His live arena events
sellout months in advance.
He's Tony Robbins
and here's my take on his
Top 10 Rules for Success,
volume two.
Rule number two is my personal favorite
and I'm curious to figure out
which one you guys like best.
And as always, guys, as
you're watching the videos,
if you hear something that
really resonates with you
please leave it down the comments below
and put quotes around it
so other people can be inspired as well.
Also, as you are writing something down
it's much more likely to
stick in your head too.
Enjoy!
(dramatic music)
- People ask what does it take to succeed?
The one answer I give them is hunger.
(dramatic music)
That hunger is the greatest asset
that you'll see in everybody
from Richard Branson to Google
or in Apple or Facebook,
these giant companies.
You got to become a master of your ability
to turn on your determination
or your creativity
or your hunger or your passion
or whatever it is that's going to take
for you to get from where you are
to where you really want to be.
Intelligence is so valuable
but there are so many smart people
that can't fight the
weight of a paper bag.
Hunger is that part of you that says
I will not stop, I will not give up,
I will not settle for less than I can be
or do or share or give.
The number one thing that's
going to change your life,
the only thing that will change your life,
change your business, change your money,
change your relationship
is you must raise your standard.
And I know that sounds
boring, stupid, basic,
but it's the truth.
The only thing that
changes our life long term
is when we raise our standards.
What does that mean?
That sounds so boring and dumb.
It means that all of us in life
have things we want,
we don't get what we want,
we get what we have to have.
Remember I said earlier,
we all get what we tolerate
in ourselves and other people
but when you're no longer
willing to tolerate something
that's when your life changes.
The difference in people
is their standards, period.
And what do I mean by standards?
Everyone in the world
has a list of things they
think they should do.
I should lose weight, I should work out,
I should spend more time with my kids,
I should work harder, I
should make more calls,
I should, I should, I should, I should
and then you know what?
People don't do their shoulds
and they get mad at themselves
and they what I call
shit all over themselves.
They beat themself up about it.
What changes people is when
your should becomes a must,
when suddenly the thing you said
should happen has to happen.
That's when human beings change.
It's like if you want to take the island
and you're the head of the army
and you want to take the island.
The most powerful way to take
the island is burn the boats
'cause if there's no way to go back
it's amazing what happens when it's a must
to do something versus I should.
That's what makes human beings succeed.
So you really have to decide.
The most important decision
is do I want to be happy?
Will I commit to being happy?
More important than happy.
Sometimes you'd be so happy,
you smile so much your face hurts, right?
You need variety.
Am I committed to living
in a beautiful state
even when it doesn't go my way?
Even when it rains on my parade?
Even when my biggest fear shows up?
Because I can't control
whether your husband or
wife will live or die
or get sick or leave you or get a divorce.
I don't want any of that to
happen to any human being.
I hate suffering.
I'd do anything I can to
help people not suffer
but I can't control that, you can.
You can, there are people
who have lost their arms,
lost their sight.
There have been people
that have been through the most
horrific experiences in life
and they found a way to still be happy
'cause they've made the decision
that life is too short to suffer.
I've interviewed dozens
and hundreds over the years
but dozens that have impacted my soul,
that made me realize I can change this.
I've just gotten used to it.
I bought into the theory
that this survival software
that's constantly running
and making you suffer,
that that's normal.
No, that's what the mind will do
and mind that's been around forever.
What I'm going to do
is something different.
And the way I get out of suffering,
I give myself a 90-second rule.
It's really simple.
I say look, if I feel myself
starting to feel that stress
feeling that pissed offness or upsetness
or concern or worry
about my kid, whatever,
I realize that's not
going to make it better,
life's too short to suffer
and then I just kind of breathe slowly,
slow everything down,
and I just watch the thought go by.
Look at that crazy thought.
'Cause everybody's had crazy thoughts.
Everybody's had a thought,
I'm going to kill that son of a, right?
And then you don't kill 'em
'cause you don't believe that thought.
It's the thoughts that are stressful
that you believe that mess you up.
When you question them,
you break the pattern.
The more I've done this, like a muscle,
the more I've trained myself to do it,
I can authentically tell
you now it takes a lot
for something to take more
than 90 seconds for me now
and the level of joy
surpasses all the money
you could ever have in a million years
and then the money, it's
easier for you to make money
'cause you're not attached.
You don't have the fears,
you don't have the
scarcity that people have
'cause you feel so rich
already, right now.
I would tell people,
don't wait to be rich.
What is that richness?
It's abundance, it's joy, it's happiness,
it's contribution, it's
getting out of yourself
'cause as long as we're thinking about
oh my god I lost something
or you did something.
Now I have less love,
less respect, less money.
If I think lost, less, or
because you did something
or because I did something
I'm never going to have
what I want in my life.
Lost, less, never.
Those three thought patterns,
they're the source of all suffering
and the antidote?
See it for what it really is,
know it's BS and find
something to appreciate.
Most people who start business
very often will start
two and three, four more
and the reason they do it
is 'cause the first one isn't succeeding
or they no longer--
- They lack patience.
- Have the juice for it.
Exactly right.
And so what happens to that person
is they're never going to
be successful in most cases
unless they get lucky.
- Yeah.
- You can get lucky
if you bounced across
something that's easier to do
but most people are always
looking for that next level.
What my view is,
is it's great to test all these things
but you've got to find
what is your flagship.
What is it that you're
going to commit your soul to
'cause if you don't do that
the inevitable channels
are going to come up
and you're going to then
move on to something else
more enjoyable.
- A 100%.
- And so the other thing I look at
is business is about constantly,
not only adding such massive value,
doing more for others than anybody else
but it's also simultaneously
about your own psychology.
It's your ability to go
through thresholds of control.
It's like, I can remember
when I didn't have $50,000
to keep the doors open on my company.
I had 12 employees and 11 wanted to quit
'cause they hated the
person running the show
and $50,000, would be like
$500 million to me today
and I figured how to get
through that threshold
and once I did,
all the problems related
to that were handled.
I know you've done this as well.
And then I, I had a five
million dollar lawsuit.
It was totally unfair and unjust
and I finally had to just,
the amount of time, energy, and money,
I had to bite the bullet and do it.
And five million was
more than I could permit.
Then I had a partner who took a company
that was losing a million dollars a day
and turned it into $1.5
billion in positive EBITDA,
I'm not mentioning names, Amway,
and he wanted me to join him in business
with some other partners
not doing the multilevel side,
did the business put in 10 million bucks,
we all put in 10 million,
it was 40 million to debt
but I signed joint and several
which I didn't understand in
those days what that meant.
And two of my partners were
supposedly billionaires
and they went broke.
We bought some more companies,
ended up with a $120 million in debt
that I was on the hook for,
no one else had any money
and I'm getting up to do a seminar,
wanting to throw up.
It was a new threshold of control.
So you know when you ski or you snowboard
and you think you're maybe,
you're just new at it
and you think you're
going down a blue a green
and it turns out to be a double black
and you're like, what the--
- Yeah!
- And so you have two choices.
One is you start to go down
and you freak out you're going to die,
you slam on the ground and
try to hang on for dear life,
or the other is you focus
on where you want to go.
- And you go.
- And you find a way to curve,
you find a way to cut,
and once you do it a couple of times--
- You get used to it.
- You have no more fear of that element.
Now, my biggest one out of that
that led me to a billion.
I have 31 companies now
to give you an idea,
seven different industries as diverse as
stem cells to virtual reality,
we have the exclusive for the
NBA now in virtually reality,
to give an example.
I got 1200 employees,
we're on three continents
and we got five billion dollars in sales
but I did that 'cause I first
stayed on one freakin' thing.
- Yeah, that's exactly right.
- Become so masterful at it.
There is another level.
The only reason you
keep seeing there isn't
is you feel so exhausted
about where you are
but life, the universe,
or God is just testing you
because there is another level.
If this is good, giant jump to excellence,
giant, start good, poor,
to good, to excellence.
There's a level where all
your dreams are realized.
There's a level that you've
always dreamed about.
It is real, it has not gone away
but it takes that extra burst.
When you think there's
nothing left, there's no way,
you've tried everything 10
million times and you keep going.
It's almost like God is saying
if you keep hitting this wall enough times
I will see that you will not stop,
that you are filled
with that level of
determination, faith, and courage
and then the door opens and
you get to that next level
but what most people don't know is
the next level is just
two millimeters above
and it's called outstanding,
ladies and gentlemen, outstanding.
What's it called?
- [Audience] Outstanding!
- What's it called?
- Outstanding, magnificent,
unstoppable, extraordinary!
Not excellent, it's a different level.
It's a level where you
are not one of the best
you are the best.
And you know what's amazing,
you only have to be two millimeters
more than everybody else
and you get everything.
You get the joy, the laughter, the fun,
the family, the passion, the economics,
the freedom, the spirit, it's all there.
What Jerry Maguire called the quad, baby.
All of it and it's just
two millimeters above
and most excellent people give up
because they're exhausted
and there's some people that go
the harder I hit it, the more I hit it,
sooner or later it's going
down, I'm not stopping.
And when you do that enough, it pops open.
If you're obsessed,
you know what you want,
you take a massive action,
maybe you modeled,
somebody figured out the right action.
So you get there quicker
and you're executing.
You still need a little grace.
Some people call it luck.
You could call it God
but I really believe that
there's the part we do
and then there's the
part that comes to us.
But I do know, grace shows up a lot more
when you do the first
two steps on your own
and grace shows up a lot more
when you acknowledge grace in your life,
when you acknowledge that
I was born in a world
where I didn't have to
build this internet,
that I can pull out of my pocket
the answer to anything on earth,
I'm driving on streets that I didn't pave,
I'm reading books I didn't have to write.
That's the gift of our lives
and I think when we experience that grace
we don't just experience more achievement
but we start to experience
more fulfillment.
- And grace not only affects
your ability to get there
but it affects what
you do and how you live
once you are there.
- It really determines
the quality of your life
because unless you live
in a state of gratitude,
I did an interview with Sir John Templeton
who as you know is one of the
first billionaire investors
and just a brilliant man.
He came from nothing and he donated,
I think it was 750,
they still do it, the Templeton Fund,
I think it's 750 million dollars a year.
It's bigger than the Nobel
Fund that he donates.
And one day I asked him I said,
"What is the secret to wealth?"
And he looked at me, paused,
this big smile and his
eyes got really bright,
like they always did and he said,
"Tony, it's what you teach."
I said, "Well I teach a lot
of things, which thing?"
And he said, "Gratitude."
He said, "Because you and I, Tony,
"know billionaires that are miserable
"and it's because they're not
grateful for what they have
"and we both know people
who have no money seemingly
"but they're so grateful for their health,
"for their husbands, for their
wife, for their children,
"they're so grateful to God,
"they're so grateful for
their life that they're rich."
So I think it starts with that gratitude,
it starts with that connection to grace
as simplistic as that sounds
and so it's not enough just
to have your financial plan.
You can have all the
money and be miserable.
Let's have the money and be really rich
emotionally, psychologically,
and spiritually.
Failure is part of life, I mean,
the difference for me though
is I look at failure as a
stepping stone to success.
It's a speed bump.
I know I'm going to fail
but it's not failure
if you learn something
and so, gosh, I've made so many mistakes.
I've screwed so many things up
but every time I do it just becomes,
it becomes a way for me
to explain to someone else what it takes.
It's like here's what I've done.
I think I have the ability
to influence people
'cause I talk about my failures,
I talk about all the
things that mess me up
but I show people that
I didn't let it stop me
and you don't need to let it stop you.
And I think that's really
the secret in that area.
- And if everything you
touched was successful
you probably wouldn't be able
to relate to people as much.
- No, you wouldn't be able to relate
and also it'd be total bull
and everyone'd know it's bull.
And also you'd be bored silly.
I mean think about it, if you just said
I want this and it happened,
people don't value what
they don't fight for.
It's like you see kids sometimes,
your parents will say you're
not going to value this
if you don't work for it.
And you're a kid you're going,
"I'll value it, just give it to me."
But it's true.
The things we've worked the hardest for,
we value the most.
So I think the purpose of the
goal is not getting it anyway.
The purpose of the goal
is what, who you become.
Who you become is going
to make you happier
or it's going to make you sad.
So I'm not looking for
an effortless approaches.
- Sure, sure, sure.
- There's no such thing.
- So Tony, one of the critics
actually that I once met said,
"Yeah Tony's techniques,
"they were great for
about a year and a half
"and then they wore off."
(Tony laughing)
What do you say to those folks who say--
- Real simple, if you don't work out
you don't get a muscle, right?
So I always tell people,
this is, there's a daily
practice like priming,
if you don't do that,
if you get up and you have
no discipline whatsoever
you get no value of anything.
Diets don't work when you don't do them,
exercise doesn't work
when you don't do them
but most of the people
that have some experiences
that they want to shift
and once you shift those things,
your whole life changes.
But life is constant growth.
My life isn't here 'cause I
went to one seminar one time
and now my life is fit for life.
I work out, I train my
mind, I train my body.
It becomes a lifestyle.
It's not just like you're
depending upon somebody else.
I'm not here to become somebody's guru.
I'm not here to give them a gift.
I'm here for them to
open up their own gifts
and that's really what my work has been.
The only way to deal with fear
that I found in my life
there's a couple ways.
One of those ways is to turn it on itself
and ask yourself what am I afraid of?
I'm afraid of that?
I got to be more afraid of
what I'm going to miss out on,
missing out on my mission,
missing out on who I'm supposed to be,
missing, in other words if
you're not getting rid of fear
than use fear, use fear or it uses you.
It's that simple.
So you got to say, okay what's the price
if I just stay doing this?
What's the price?
I need to really get scared
if I learn all this and
I don't follow through.
That's something to be scared about
and then that fear will
get you over your fear.
It'll push you through,
turn fear in itself.
Second way you can do it
is use what you've probably heard me say
'cause I've used it since I was 17,
is my little rocking chair test, right?
I'm going to sit myself
in my rocking chair.
I'm 85 years old and
looking back on my life
and I say, I didn't do this or I did.
If you find your passion,
you're going to have
this tremendous energy
of sustainable energy
but momentum requires you
always do the next thing
that keeps the momentum going
and the reason you get
yourself in a passionate place
is so that you change your life
and the only thing that changes your life
is making a decision.
So while you're in this passionate state
that's where you make decisions.
You don't make decisions when you're like,
oh I don't know, what do you think?
All right let's decide.
If you make a decision in
a state without momentum,
if you make a decision
from a place where there's no passion,
you are not going to get momentum.
It will kill momentum.
It's decide, commit and resolve.
Some of you in the past,
you've gotten momentum,
you've gotten passionate,
you've even made a decision
but a decision is the first step,
decision is like a war,
I got to do this or that.
Alright, I'm going to make myself do this
but commitment is when you nail
after you've decided you commit
to do this for the long term
whether it's hard or easy doesn't matter,
you're doing this.
It takes it from this moment
and it carries it into the future
even when things are difficult.
And the third state is resolve.
Resolved means it's done.
It's like, it doesn't
even if you took action,
it's done inside you
so it's done out there.
There's no question whatsoever.
Then once you decide,
the only way the commitment
and the energy and the momentum continues
is if you take immediate
massive, what my friends?
Massive what?
Write down in your notes.
Massive action is the cure-all.
If you're having a difficult
time with something,
your relationship isn't
where you want it to be,
your finances are not
where you want to be,
your body is not where you want to be,
your business is not where you want to be.
you need to take massive action!
And if that doesn't
work, try something else.
If that doesn't work try something else.
Keep going with massive action
and you will find the way
because it will give you momentum.
- Thank you guys so much for watching.
We're continuing to experiment
with the volume two series
so I hope you enjoyed it.
I'd love to know what did Tony say here
that had the biggest
impact on you and why?
What are you going to
immediately apply somehow
to your life or your business?
Please leave it down in the comments below
and I'm going to join in the discussion.
I also want to give a
quick shout to D Green.
Thank you so much, man,
for picking up a copy of
my book, Your One Word,
and making that awesome silent
tribute video on YouTube.
I really appreciate your
creativity and your support.
(playful music)
So thank you guys again for watching.
I believe in you.
I hope you continue to believe in yourself
and whatever your one word is, much love.
I'll see you soon.
- 'Cause you'll never earn
your way to financial fortune.
Even people that make just loads of money,
the actors, the actresses, the athletes.
Where are they 10 and 15 years later?
I mean 50 Cent made a
hundred million dollars
on vitamin water, he got a tip.
And he got like a two or
300 million dollar net worth
and he's bankrupt.
He bought Mike Tyson's
house, 25,000 square feet
and Mike Tyson made a
half a billion dollars
and went bankrupt.
Right now, I don't know
if you saw, Johnny Depp,
I don't know if it's
going to happen or not
but the papers are saying
he may go bankrupt.
He made three quarters of a
billion dollars as a movie star
but he spent $30,000 a month on wine.
He must be feeling good
and secondly he took Hunter
Thompson, the reporter,
he burned his body
and paid three million dollars
to blow his ashes into
the sky in a cannon.
So no matter how much money you make,
you can screw it up, right?
But if you will just decide,
there's a percentage of my
income that no matter what
I'm going to have it automated,
I'm not going to see it.
It's going to go straight
to an investment account.
And I don't know if it's 10 or 15 or 20.
Those numbers sound
gigantic to most people.
Even if you start with five and build
that income does not go to anybody else
and then you put that into compounding.
So listen to this.
There's a young man, true story,
a Theodore Johnson, 1950s, worked for UPS.
Never made more than
$14,000 in annual income
in his entire life,
retired with $70 million and
he didn't inherit a dime.
He gave away 35 million
while he was alive.
Now how is that possible?
Because of compound interest.
I interview all these investors
and say what's the biggest
mistake Americans make
he said, they all said
they don't tap into compound interest.
They know intellectually
a little bit what it means
but they don't do it,
they don't do it consistently.
So what do you do?
- It basically just means
that the profits you made
could go back into the investment.
- You keep reinvesting
and it keeps growing
but it grows geometrically, right?
And so a friend of his came
to this man who worked for UPS
and said I'm going to make you rich.
We're going to put a 20% tax on you,
he said I can't give up 20%.
I can't pay my bills if I do that.
He said listen,
if the government raise your taxes 20%
and you'd claim, you'd
screamed, you'd cry,
you'd complain and you'd pay it
and you get adjusted to it
but he said this is not
going to the government,
this is going into an
account for your future
and that compounding is what
made him that much money.
In the book, I give you an
example of an 18-year-old boy
whose father convinces
him that he should save
$300 a month out of his income.
not a huge income that sounds like a lot.
But when you automate it,
you forget about it, it's perfect.
You adjust.
Well he does this from 18 years
old to 27 for eight years.
So the total amount of
money $300 a month's
about 4,000 a year, that's $28,000 total.
He didn't put, he leaves it in the market
and never adds a dime to
it from 28 years old on.
At 65, because the market
over those 30 years grew 10%
his money has compounded so
much he has $1.8 million.
You don't need a lot
of money to be wealthy.
You need time.
- So you're saying that
even if I have student debt,
that I'm struggling to pay off.
Even if I'm making say $1,000 a week,
that I should still
try to put a percentage
or make it a point to put a percentage
not just into a savings account
but into an investment account.
- Into an investment account,
where to put that money,
then we teach you the ways to do that.
It's got to be diversified.
- Yeah.
- Never put all your money in the market.
- I want to, okay.